ynr returns today with the first new
episode since production shut down
17 weeks ago now while the residents of
genoa city seem to always be going
through some drama
it is nothing compared to what one of
its most iconic stars melody thomas
scott survived in real life growing up
with her grandmother
her behavior got worse and worse and
worse
so by the time i was a teenager it was
just
madness she also allowed men to
sexually abuse you in order to get work
i think she felt that whatever had to
happen in order to get
ahead in show business would be okay
she would watch it there um
and and watch because i would see her
doing it with
wild eyes of like do you see what's
happening here
please save me and there would be no
savings
melody was just eight years old when she
started her acting career
raised by her grandmother who she claims
pushed for stardom at any cost the now
64 year old is sharing disturbing
details of her traumatic upbringing
it taught me strength that's for sure i
knew i had to be strong to survive
her i am at the time of my life where i
want
peace the ynr star tells her story in
her new memoir
always young and restless reminiscing
about her nearly six decade career
including how she was almost cast as
marsha brady
actually maureen mccormick and i
were friends but i was either too short
or too tall
and that was it for me uh i mean it was
very cut and dry
that's it and her 34 year marriage to
bold and beautiful supervising producer
ed scott do you remember
several years back you and ed renewed
your vows
uh for an e.t wedding special absolutely
i love you i love you i remember at
first we didn't want to do it
guys we thought we're old-fashioned and
we thought what what is there to renew
we're still married we're still happy we
had such a good time
the actress who's played nicki newman
for the last 40 years holds nothing back
even her decision to have a neck lift
last december why'd you decide to do
that now
you know i always thought i'm gonna age
gracefully
my husband was of the same mind and all
of a sudden you have three chins and
all this stuff i looked at i said this
is unacceptable
i cannot have this nikki would never
look this way
and i have to do something about it and
i wish i had done it
sooner what has it been like being back
how has the landscape changed for you
guys
we've been back for two weeks and so far
i have not witnessed any love scenes uh
so i have a feeling they're not going to
do any
until a little more down the road and in
the meantime we all have to be on guard
are you going to have to kiss a victor
newman stand in dog that's what i
that will never happen
there is no stand-in that would look
enough like him
not happening